so you both are christians followers of
jesus and you both admit that you had
porn addictions yes yeah walk us through
that well as a kid i was sexually abused
um
about the age of seven or eight and that
exposed me to to porn and so then as i
got the internet it was like oh this is
this is a jackpot
i got a computer to like start producing
music and i did but then it also opened
me up i'm like start producing right
here
and so that that was a stronghold over
over my life like that was an addiction
for for a while and i carried some of
that what do you consider a porn
addiction what does that mean when you
don't want to do something but you do it
anyway when i go ah i feel convicted i
know this doesn't help this doesn't help
high view women this doesn't help how i
uh view my own sexuality this doesn't
help anything this this causes shame and
i can't control it i think when you
can't control something it's an
addiction right when you when you it
controls you it controls you and that's
definitely what it was and so then
getting married and and uh my wife was
you know she wasn't she didn't have a
bunch of sexual partners and so like
then taking that into marriage so
definitely so i'm speaking as someone as
on the other side of being freed from
this
the majority of men i'm dealing with
this isn't causing a net positive to
their life this is this is this is
hurting them this is um inhibiting and i
guess the the the pros of of
of uh only fans is that at least the
creators are in control yeah
historically porn has been really bad a
lot of overlap with human trafficking
yeah uh really toxic stuff so i think
the only a positive i would say is like
well at least the creators are in
control at least as far as i know this
isn't connected to sex trafficking where
there's pimps
that was a real thing 10 years ago so
but but i would just still i would ask
man the dude that's looking at this
stuff
is this causing him to add a net
positive to society is this causing him
to be or is this causing him to insulate
deeper to
grow more dysfunctional have more issues
with his mental health um and so that
that's how i would that's how i would
look at it on a macro scale and then i
think from the creation of said content
uh then you filter that out so it's less
about what you and your husband do in in
your guys home it's more like
does it distort and does it add a net
positive to society and i think it's
hard to justify that why don't you add
in the cause tell us what you were
dealing with and then how you uh
religion or your husband have helped
this problem so um
my
my
i was exposed to it at a very young age
as well um
porn yeah
um and i've actually talked about this
openly on my channel as well and i was
the ugly
duckling right i was the i was the ugly
kid at school so i was looking at it as
how can i get love like this is my idea
of love right
this person click you know as and as a
child you don't know what this actually
is right your brain hasn't developed
enough to understand fully grasp what
you're watching and what you're seeing
and so for me i thought well this is
what
people in love do
right
and yes it is sex is a beautiful thing
in the in the context of marriage um but
i kept going down the rabbit hole and it
get it kept getting
worse and worse and what i was exposed
to
should have never been
allowed to
be filtered through my eyes at what age
like
13 14. yeah and you say getting worse
and worse and worse was getting worse i
i was seeking out more and more perverse
pornography
and this happens right the it's the
dopamine hit it hits you
and then that's like okay that that was
good for a short period of time now i
gotta re-up right it's just like a it's
just like a
a substance abuse the more you get
exposed to it the more that you want to
get more and that's not fulfilling your
needs anymore so what is going to
fulfill those needs and so
you know i got counseling i had to
really
i had to really restructure my brain and
understand like
one
i yes i have responsibility in this
but at the same time it's like okay
let's rework how relationships actually
are
women are not objects we're you know
like like rousson said
we're image bearers of god and so
for me and my husband my husband my
husband has talked about this as well
also addicted to porn
and um we you know we have you guys were
dealing with the exact same problem yes
but prior to you guys yes yes yeah prior
um and so there's tools and resources
out there
for people like uh covenant eyes
but
you know it's really hard and you have
to really come to terms with this like
this happening in my room as a child
isolating myself and this happens to
women too it's not just men
and a lot of younger a lot of young
women get into this very early in their
lives so
you know it happens to both people and
luckily i got
my
situation figured out and the right
therapy about it but yeah it's it's very
scary so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire size cast click
right here
[Music]